smoke darkens the skies above
aleppo's countryside syrian
russian-backed forces have launched an
offensive to seize the area syrian armed
group Hayate a polish armed is fighting
back the new battlefront is close to the
capital Damascus in the north but
civilians are caught in the fighting my
uncle's house was hit by a missile his
wife was in the kitchen and she was
killed the strike was so severe that the
missile penetrated into the lower floor
government forces have been making
important gains most recently the town
of maarat al-nouman nearby and Saraqeb
fighting is also taking place in densely
populated areas that's despite a
ceasefire deal agreed between Turkey and
Russia
it's another strategic town as it's near
the m4 highway that runs west to east
across it lib the casualty numbers are
growing on earth sides a center for
rescue workers the white helmets was
reduced to rubble and some wounded
fighting has extended to the
northwestern town of Al Bob which was
under ISIL control three years ago one
missile hit the Turkish backed Free
Syrian Army and opposition positions
Turkey has since sent a military
reinforcements to it'd Lib president
reject hype r1 warned on Friday that
Turkey could intervene if the violence
escalates air strikes and a ground
advance by the Syrian government has
given people only one option to flee
packing their cars and trucks with
whatever they can carry others haven't
had homes for years forced to move on to
other places several times now some live
in makeshift camps on the side of the
road I don't know where we are I don't
even know which ways in metal sound we
all suffered so much in carnal our soul
with all the airstrikes if we don't get
help we'll go to sleep hungry we don't
own anything we can't afford to buy food
and the young are suffering the most the
UN says the situation is turning into a
crisis for children more than 6,500 have
been forced from their homes in the past
week there are about 3 million people in
this area these are people these are
civilians who are trapped in a war zone
so you know this is why we're so shocked
and horrified at the continued military
onslaught on the civilian population
because you know the international
humanitarian law must apply aid groups
say there are shortages of food water
and medicine and if the bombardment
doesn't stop it could soon create one of
Syria's worst humanitarian disasters
Rahila mohammad al jazeera